Once Upon a Time Panasonic was one of
the largest electronic brands in the
world making everything from TVs and
appliances to batteries and phones they
were the pride of Japan alongside Sony
and Toshiba throughout the mid to late
1900s as they recovered from the
devastating ruins of World War II but
the 2000s haven't been so nice to
Panasonic they've shut down their
Communications business much of their TV
business and even their LCD business
they've also been forced to sell off
many of their assets including their
security business their semiconductor
business and most notably their entire
$3.5 billion taken Tesla it's not
looking much better internally either
Panasonic's Revenue has fallen by over
40% their gross profit has nearly haved
and they've written off tens of billions
of dollars worth of losses as such their
employee count has shrunk by over
100,000 people within the past 13 years
honestly the only thing at Panasonic
that hasn't hasn't gone straight down is
ironically their stock price but this
isn't all that much better anyway as the
stock has basically just been going
sideways for the past 30 years and when
you account for inflation you'll see
that Panasonic stock is actually down
66% over the past 30 years seeing all
this I decided to check the bankruptcy
probability for Panasonic usually for
the big tech companies the probability
is less than 1% for more distressed
companies like GoPro the number is
usually in the low double digit
so with that in mind do you want to
guess how much it is for Panasonic maybe
70 or 80% well it's straight up over
100% this is something that I've never
seen before so odds are that unless a
miracle happens or the Japanese
government steps in someone who's
already drowning in debt Panasonic is as
good as dead but what happened as far as
I can remember there was never really
any any pivotal moment for the company
they kind of just slowly lost team over
the course of decades right well there
is actually a lot more to the story as
much of Panasonic's demise can be
attributed to them forgetting about
their Roots so join me as we take a look
back at the rise and fall of Panasonic
and try to pinpoint what went
wrong Panasonic's Fall From Grace shows
how even major corporations can falter
when they lose sight of their core
strengths this iconic Japanese brand
went from Electronics giant to
borderline bankruptcy by failing to
adapt to changing Technologies and
markets now everyday investors face
their own challenges finding stable
returns amidst economic uncertainty just
last week the Federal Reserve opted to
pause rates leaving us with a historic
High interest rate of
5.25% invest inting in bonds now means
locking in high rates before the Federal
Reserve starts decreasing them once
again companies and legendary investors
are well aware of this and that's why
they've been investing hundreds of
billions into bonds over the past year
if you'd like to leverage these high
interest rates for yourself that's where
Silo our upcoming Bond investing
platform comes into play with Silo you
can not only invest in treasuries but
you can also invest in bonds issued by
corporations such as Apple Nike or
Coca-Cola all with no markups and
$500,000 in sipc insurance and $2.5
million in FDIC insurance if that sounds
worthwhile please consider checking out
Silo in the description below but anyway
taking a look back the story of
Panasonic dates back to November 27th
1894 to a man named konosuke matushita
konosuke was born to a poor rice farming
family and was the youngest of five
daughters and three sons by the time
that konosu was just 4 years old his
father would end up losing their entire
family form as he speculated on the rice
exchange having lost everything konos
su's father would head to the city to
find a job but that wasn't enough pretty
soon young konosuke himself would have
to start working at just age n he would
start off at a hiachi store before
moving on to a bicycle store but while
the circumstances weren't that great
these jobs taught konosuke a great deal
about the business world how do you
attract customers how do you keep them
happy how do you keep employees loyal
and most importantly how to walk away
with a modest profit during these long
days of work konosuke would start seeing
street cars pop up outside the store and
this would convince him that the future
of business had to do with electricity
so at age 15 he decided to leave his gig
at the bicycle shop and join the Osaka
electric light company as a natural hard
worker konosuke would rapidly rise up
the ranks and become an ins Spector by
the time that he was just 22 it's crazy
to think that by this point he already
had 13 years of work experience seven of
which were in the electrical business
all of this hard work had allowed konuk
to escape the depths of poverty but
konosuke had far larger Ambitions and
this is when he would start butting
heads with the management in his early
20s for example he would design an
improved light socket and Pitch it to a
supervisor but his supervisor would
simply dismiss the idea claiming that it
was useless and would go nowhere
invigorated by these remarks konosuke
would decide to quit his job and try his
handed business and with that he would
set up shop inside his tiny two room
apartment with his wife and
brother-in-law in June of
1917 if this was a Darman video konos
su's new light socket would end up going
viral and he would end up buying out his
old employer and stick it to his old
supervisor but unfortunately it wasn't
and unfortunately konos su's light
socket wouldn't go anywhere in fact
things were so bad that he would have to
sell the few valuables that he still had
just to get by unwilling to quit though
konosuke continued experimenting and
creating new products and after several
months he would finally land on a
product that someone actually wanted
insulation plates for fans this product
gave him enough money to sustain himself
leading to the creation of Matsushita
Electric AKA Panasonic on March 7th
1918 but while things were going
decently well with the installation
plates konos still didn't have the heart
to just give up on the light sockets so
he would revisit and redesign a socket
leading to the creation of two new
products an attachment plug and a
two-way socket unlike konos su's
original light socket these new sockets
would gain steam almost immediately
which brings us into konos su's first
principle always keep experimenting even
if your first idea doesn't work it's
more than likely that some iteration of
it would in fact konosuke felt so strong
about this that he would keep a pencil
and paper by his bedside at all times
this way if he got any new ideas in his
sleep he could jot them down and put
them to work anyway the momentum of this
new socket allowed konosuke to move his
operation to a larger two-story house
and scal his Workforce to 20 employees
marking the beginning of Panasonic's
Monumental
run moving into the 1920s things were
going much better Panasonic had turned
into a legitimate local business but
that isn't to say that the road ahead
was always smooth in fact konosuke would
find himself in another difficult
situation with this next product itself
what hurt the most with this product was
that going into it konos was sure that
it was going to be a banger it was one
of those ideas that he got while
sleeping and woke up thinking Eureka
what was this product you ask well it
was a simple bicycle light battery
powered lights were already a thing but
they were completely impractical as they
only lasted 2 to 3 hours so most people
including konosuke himself resorted to
using a candle lamp when biking
frustrated by this reality konosuke
would spend 6 months designing a bullet
shied bicycle lamp that was truly
revolutionary lasting 30 to 40 hours
excited konosuke would strike deals with
a bunch of wholesalers and stock stores
all across the city but to his utter
disappointment not a soul would buy
these lamps why you asked
well because people had already made up
their mind that battery powered lamps
sucked konosuke kept holding out hope
that the strength of their product would
shine through in this overlooked Market
but it never happened to make things
worse the Great kto Earthquake would
strike in September of 1923 which
destroyed much of his sales Partners but
by now I think you know that konosuke
never quits 4 years later he would come
back to the bicycle lamp Market with a
square shaped lamp now nothing much had
changed internally but kuki approach to
selling these lamps was completely
different for starters the light was an
odd square shape something that people
had never seen before this was very much
on purpose it was to emphasize that the
light itself was nothing like people had
used before konosuke also bought out
newspaper ads that read National lamps
buy for your Assurance use for your
benefit and to round it all off konosuke
would hand out 10,000 samples to stores
without any sort of obligation the
result well konosuke would end up
selling 30,000 units per month by the
end of the first year itself which
brings us into konos su's second
principle good products don't sell
themselves just because you have a good
product doesn't mean that people will
line up outside your door wanting to buy
it even a good product requires an even
better marketing campaign having
realized this with the bicycle lamp
kosuke would vow to never let marketing
screw over a good product and with that
he would completely restructure the
company in 1929 he would create four
cinct divisions one for each of their
major product categories electrical
sockets batteries bicycle lamps and
radios each of these divisions had their
own national sales department with
regional departments underneath them and
to top it off konos sui would directly
link each sales department with their
respective manufacturing Department this
way manufacturing was directly dependent
on sales reducing the likelihood of
overproduction or underproduction with
this brand new Salesforce in place
Panasonic would enter the 1930s with
pure dominance as they grew to be a
national player employing over 10,000
people but just as Panasonic was hitting
a stride World War II would roll
[Music]
around there's really no easy way to put
it World War II destroyed Panasonic
throughout the war Panasonic struggled
to get materials and higher Talent as
young men were being recruited to the
war to make things worse the company was
forced to focus on industrial production
efforts for the war kuki was hopeful
that things would get better after the
war but they only got worse as I think
we all know how the war came to an end
Japan was literally bombed into Oblivion
which not only destroyed everything that
konos sui had built but what the entire
country had built and just when you
thought that things couldn't get any
worse general Douglas MacArthur and the
Americans would begin occupying the
country and basically take control and
one of their reform orders was for konuk
to step down and relinquish control of
Panasonic konosuke didn't even resist
but you know who did his 15,000
employees who signed a petition to keep
konosuke in power they argued that
konosuke was a vital part of their
reconstruction effort and that removing
him would basically destroy the company
fortunately for Panasonic konos sui's
resignation order would end up getting
rescinded allowing konuk to continue
leading the company but while konuk had
somehow managed to keep control of his
company he had lost all momentum any
normal person would have been distraught
beyond belief but konosuke was never the
pessimistic type in fact he was rather
optimistic which brings us into his
thirdd Core Business principle good
times are good and bad times are even
better you see konos believ that
downturns were the perfect time to
evaluate the state of a business and
reinvent it when things are going well
you're usually scared to do something
different and screw up what you already
have but when things are going bad well
you've got nothing left to lose so you
might as well take a risk and see if
that unlocks a whole new level and
that's exactly what konos suuk would do
he would tell his employees to approach
the business with the attitude that they
had just opened which wasn't that far
from the truth given that Panasonic
would start targeting a completely
different Market the global market to be
honest penasonic had no other choice
given that the Japanese economy was in
no state to support so many employees by
themselves so the entire 1950s was
focused on launching Western Products
this included washing machines TVs
refrigerators radios portable radios
rice cookers tape recorders and ACS this
was also around the time that the name
Panasonic actually came about given the
new international Focus they needed an
easy English name and they would settle
on Panasonic pan means Universal and
Sonic means sound so Panasonic was
supposed to signify by the company
bringing the sound of Japan to the
entire world and this new name marked
the beginning of Panasonic's Golden Era
the ' 60s 7s and ' 80s but as we now
know this Golden Era wouldn't last
forever it's sad to say but Panasonic's
Peak basically aligns exactly with konos
sui's death in 1989 ever since kuk died
it it has only been downhill for
Panasonic and it's no wonder why they
basically completely forgot about the
principles that made the business
successful in the first place take konos
su's principle of always keep
experimenting for example after konos
su's death Panasonic completely stopped
experimenting and if you don't want to
believe me just take it from their own
website here's other products they
launched in the ' 50s here's all the
products they launched in the ' 60s and
'70s here's all the products they
launched in the ' 80s and even '90s and
here's all the products they launched in
the 2000s yeah you're not looking at
that wrong there's not even a single
product listed on there their last
notable product was way back in '98 when
they launched digital TVs for the US you
can only hit the ball out of the park if
you try swinging Panasonic has not swung
in 25 years but not only has Panasonic
shied away from new products but they've
also dropped the ball on their existing
products you know how we talked about
how there was no pivotal moment for
Panasonic it wasn't like their products
just suddenly sucked or their pricing
went through the roof for anything like
that the reality is that Panasonic
products are still quite great but the
thing to keep in mind is that great
products don't sell themselves and this
is perfectly exemplified by Samsung
Samsung ranks lower than Panasonic
across the board when it comes to
product quality pricing and customer
service but Samsung is worth over 10
times Panasonic you know why because
Samsung knows how to Market their
product whether it's appliances TVs or
smartphones seriously when was the last
time that you saw a Panasonic ad I bet
the answer is too long ago to remember
now when was the last time that you saw
a Samsung ad I bet the answer is too
recently to remember basically anytime
you're browsing the web or watching a
video or shopping or driving you
probably saw Samsung branding but you
probably don't even remember because
you're so desensitized to it with this
level of marketing discrepancy it's no
wonder why people choose Samsung or LG
when buying a new TV or new appliances
good products don't sell themselves
Panasonic's competitors understand this
Panasonic doesn't something else that
Panasonic doesn't seem to understand is
that downturns can be a blessing back in
the ' 40s Panasonic had lost basically
everything but they were able to make it
work by not losing hope and shifting
gears the early 2000s would have been
the perfect time to do this again
imagine if they were the first person to
jump onto the smartphone Trend instead
of Samsung or if they were the ones to
capitalize on Ola technology they could
have made a name for themselves in the
modern tech era but instead it seems
that Panasonic has lost hope which is
likely the most disappointing part of
all of this whether it was the failed
light socket or the bicycle lamp or
World War II
one thing that remained constant was
kono's optimism for the future modern
Panasonic on the other hand seems to
have lost all hope they're not
experimenting marketing or leveraging
their downturn it almost seems like
they've already accepted defeat and are
just trying to hold on for as long as
possible and with this sort of mindset
it's no wonder why they're biting us on
the wall for their bankruptcy another
Legacy giant that's actually managing to
make a turnaround is Nokia check out
this video to learn more but until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next
one